[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEVE BAZYL: Hi everyone.
Thanks for coming.
We're back after a small
delay this morning.
We were supposed to be on
earlier this morning at 10:00.
A few little scheduling mishaps,
but everything got
worked out fine.
So, no worries, and we're glad
to be back with today's topic
of questions from
the community.
There are few that were
posted already.
If you are watching and you
would like to ask additional
questions, feel free
to just post
something in the community.
You can do that either on the
original event that was
announced or just add a new
topic in the discussions, and
I'll get to those at the
end, if there are any.
If not, no big deal.
We'll be doing these
again now and then.
And of course, we'll always be
happy to answer whatever
question you ask, either
in the community or in
StackOverflow.
So I'm going to take a quick
look down at a few that were
asked on the original event--
a couple of good ones in here
that I think are interesting.
The first, from Will Scott, is
asking about how our Open and
Create actions work in
the context of mobile
applications.
And this is actually a really
good question, because you're
right that these URLs are
somewhat meaningless on a
mobile application,
particularly if
it's a native app.
And for Android, this is
something that we're actually
handling partially
through intents.
So the way that you can handle
and Open With-like action with
the native Drive client
is through a
special Drive Open intent.
And there is an Android example
in the docs that shows
how to take advantage of this.
Apps can also just use the
regular Open intent as well
just to handle any generic
file open.
But if you want to get specific
drive metadata and
handle things in a different
way-- where you handle the
file transfer yourself, get
the file ID so you can do
uploads and everything--
the Drive Open action is the
one that you'd want to take
advantage of.
On iOS, we're a little
bit behind there.
It's something that
we are looking at.
And I would just say, in
general, the integration with
native apps on mobile is not
quite to the level that it
really should be compared to the
integration that we have
in the Drive UI on the web.
This is something that's
important to us, of course, so
stay tuned over the next few
months as we refine that
experience and give you a
few more options on the
development side to have those
apps nicely integrated with
the Drive applications
on Android and iOS.
But today, we're not quite
there, other than
Open With on Android.
And again, take a look at the
examples that are already
there today.
Arnie had a good
question here.
It's a little bit more of
a product question.
So I'm not going to go into too
much detail about this,
but he was asking, how do
we optimize disk space?
And this is somebody who's
trying to move some of his
attachments into Drive from
Gmail but, of course,
wondering about the storage and
quota usage of having two
copies of the attachments.
So a couple people have pointed
to some really helpful
tools to help do some of this
stuff automatically.
These are some apps that have
been written in Apps Script,
which is actually a great way to
do this kind of automation.
From a product perspective, I
can't really say of any plans
that we're doing other than
just, in general, we're always
looking for opportunities to
improve the integration
between Drive and other products
to make this a more
seamless experience for users.
So expect the products
to evolve.
Expect the integrations to
evolve, what they end up
looking like.
I don't know, but obviously,
we're very interested in
making this as seamless as an
experience for you as a user
and for developers as well.
So I want to go back, and a good
question from Alexei--
is there a way to generate a
preview for custom files in
Google Drive?
They are creating and editing
specific files, and they have
the capability to generate a
PNG and JPG and then would
like it to display,
presumably, in
the thumbnail view.
Or [? she ?] just recently
was some redesigns
of how we do previews.
So the answer to that is yes.
This is probably a poorly
documented feature.
It's something we launched back
in October, probably did
a blog post on it.
But in terms of the
documentation, it's actually
just buried.
It's one field on the Files
resource and then a small
blurb somewhere in our docs.
And we were actually just
talking about this the other
day, about how we can make this
a lot more prominent,
because we think it's actually
a really cool feature,
particularly with some
improvements in the Drive UI
to make previews much
more prominent.
The short answer is when you
upload the file metadata,
there is a property
that you can set.
It's just called Thumbnail.
And it takes the base64 encoded
data for your thumbnail.
You can upload anything up to
about two megabytes in size.
The higher the resolution
you can do to fit
inside that the better.
Anything above 1600,
though, probably
isn't going to be used.
We will downsample and downsize
that thumbnail for
the appropriate views.
We won't, however, try
to upsample it.
So try to give us as big as
a one you can within two
megabytes, base64 encode it,
shove it in the thumbnail
property, and we will take
advantage of that.
There are a couple
catches to that.
So any time that the binary
content changes--
so if this is a file that
you're storing the BLOB,
you're storing the raw
data in Drive--
any time that the content
changes, you do need to
provide a new thumbnail because
that's going to get
invalidated.
If you're using more of the
shortcut-style applications
where you're only storing
metadata in Drive but the
content is held elsewhere, we're
not going to invalidate
those when the content changes
because we simply don't know
when the content changes.
But it would just be your
responsibility to make sure
that those thumbnails are
updated on an appropriate
basis so that they reflect
the content of the file.
But yeah, it's a cool feature.
If you have custom files in
Drive, strongly encouraged to
do, especially now that
thumbnailing and preview usage
is becoming much more prominent
in the Drive UI.
So next question is are there
plans for public HTML hosting?
To enhance this, so this is the
HTML hosting feature we
launched a little while ago.
It would be nice to have some
Apps Script integrations and
version managers and so on.
So these are actually really
good suggestions.
So some of this is already
available in Drive.
So version management, for
example, Drive is a version
file system, so the revision
history is there.
Those revisions do get cleaned
up periodically in the
background.
So if, as a user, you want to
keep them around, you have to
go in and you have to pin
certain revisions if you want
to guarantee that you can always
roll back to them.
It's not really featured
prominently in the UI, and nor
is the UI really an IDE
or an authoring
tool for HTML content.
But there are some really cool
ones that people are building
in the Chrome Web Store.
There are some apps like
Neutron Drive.
There's ShiftEdit--
can't remember the name of it.
But there's a couple of really
cool Cloud IDEs that are being
backed by Drive.
I don't know which of those
have a nice revision
management integrated.
But if you're the developer of
those and you haven't done it,
that would be a really
good thing to add.
And then in terms of Apps Script
integration, that's a
really good question.
I don't know the answer to that
right now, but I do know
that the Apps Script team is
very interested and always
adding features and making
it easier to build
apps with Apps Script.
They are a, I would say,
cousin of Drive.
Definitely, we have
a common origin.
But there's probably a
lot that we can do.
Nothing that I can really talk
about or say concretely, but
it's something that we'll talk
to those teams about and see
how can we make these features
work really well together?
And it's probably something
that would be really
interesting and fun
to work on.
So let's see, Alexei says he'd
like to run some code on an
event in Google Drive, such as a
file or folder creation, and
Edit, like a new version.
Are there ways to do it?
Yes.
So there's a couple options.
One is, as, actually, somebody
pointed out the in the
threads, you can use Apps
Script, which does have some
basic triggering support.
If your code can't run in the
Apps Script container--
you want to run code on your
other thing, and you don't
want to have that glue code
where you're using the
triggers of Apps Script but
then having to call out to
another service--
there is a way to do it
with the Changes feed.
So any modification to a user's
collection is reported
as a change in the feed.
You can poll that feed to
get a list of all the
modifications since the
last time you checked.
So polling may be an option if
the frequency that you poll at
isn't too high.
If it's OK that there's a little
bit of a delay for when
that action happens and when you
need to know about it, you
can poll every 10, 15
minutes, and that
would be totally fine.
For more real time, reactive
stuff's, the Apps Script
integration will give you a
little bit better accuracy, or
at least a smaller window.
And then something that we
announced a few weeks ago when
we talked about our Early
Access Program is we are
working on Push notifications,
which does give you that lower
latency, chance to subscribe
to files, subscribe to
folders, and get notified when
they changed or if an item is
added to a collection
or so on.
So some things, you could do
today, depending on your use
case, either Apps Script
or polling.
In the future, we're going
to make it a little
bit better with Push.
And then yeah, you should be
able to do that just fine.
And there's a whole
bunch of apps that
are doing this today.
There's some really cool
services like IFTT--
If This Then That.
There's a couple on mobile
devices that do this type of
automation.
Another used to be
called Wappwolf.
Now it's called iBeam.it.
Really, just awesome apps that
are doing exactly what you
described of watching Drive or
Dropbox or any other service--
they're doing Twitter.
You name it, they're watching
it and allowing you to do
these types of triggers.
So that's actually even another
option is going to
somebody who already has an
infrastructure and see if you
can piggyback on that and do
your own custom actions for
one of these services
like IFTT.
Let's see what else.
So I'm going to jump up to the
top here, and actually it
looks like there may even
be a few new posts.
This one from Colby, of course,
which is, yes, did
anyone else get tricked into
watching the YouTube video
this morning?
Yes.
No.
Of course we're sorry about
that, but it's fine.
Better late than never.
Tom had a good question about
Drive scopes on Android.
And it's actually a really
important question.
So I was thinking, can we do
things, more restrictive than
just asking for everything
in Drive on Android?
And you can.
There is one particular
catch, and it brings
up a broader point.
So we do have the drive.file
scope.
This is something that when we
did Drive version one, this
was actually the only
scope that we had.
And then in version two,
we added the full
scope back in again.
That used to be in the
Documents List API.
And the drive.file scope
does work with Android.
What this will allow you to do
is have access to any file
that your application creates
as well as any file that the
user explicitly opens.
So in the case of you were doing
the Drive Open intent.
Somebody launches a file
from the Drive UI.
That will enable your app to
open and read that file.
But everything else
is off limits.
And this is exactly the
type of use case
that Tom asked for.
The catch, though, on Android
is you have to be using the
newer ways of authenticating
and gaining access--
basically, using Google
Play services.
The reason has to do with how
application identity is
established.
If you're using the older,
pre-Google Play services
methods of authenticating and
authorizing access to your
app, you're actually, even
though you're getting access
for the user, the application
that we see it as is actually
just Android.
It's not your specific
application.
And so when it comes to doing
this fine grain permissioning,
that doesn't really work,
because it means every
application on that device would
have access to the same
set of files, which is really
not what the intention of that
feature is nor what the
user would expect.
And so a while back, we actually
turned off that
feature, at least for
using the shared ID.
If you use the Google Play
Services, GoogleAuthUtil,
basically, that capability
is restored.
So when we see a request from
your app, it actually maps
back to a project in the Google
API's console, and we
have a really strong way of
establishing that identity.
And then we know for sure
that, yes, this is your
application.
These are the files that the
user authorized you to see,
and then we can have that
level of security again.
So if you switch over to using
that take-up, it can then use
the drive.file scope and then
have the level of security
that you are looking for.
One thing we're actually
planning to do later in July
is disable use of the older
authorization mechanism for
Drive completely.
And it's not necessarily from
a security perspective, just
because if you're using the full
Drive scope, every app
has access to every
file anyway.
It's really just more for
quota management, for
reporting, just make sure
that we have a much
more accurate picture.
Plus, the new way of doing it
is just much more secure in
general, and we really want
to get people using it.
So if you're not using Google
Play services yet, already, on
Android, switch now, just get
it out there to your users.
And then sometime around June
or July, if you're still on
the old way, we're going to
start turning that off, and
chances are, your
apps will break.
So obviously, you don't
want that to happen.
And it's only a handful
of apps that are
still on the old one.
We'll be reaching out to people
individually just to
make sure people are
keeping up to date.
But for anyone doing a new
app, Play services
is the way to go.
David had a really good
question, actually related to
this, is there a way to limit
applications to a folder?
Currently, the answer is no.
So as I explained earlier,
we have just these two
[INAUDIBLE].
One is everything, and then
the other is down to an
individual file basis.
The idea of doing it on a folder
basis is something that
we've heard quite a bit
of from developers.
It's something that we've been
working with the engineering
team to figure out if we can
have this and what that
timing might be.
There are various technical
issues that are keeping us
from doing it as soon as we
would like to, but it's
definitely something we've
gotten a lot of requests for,
something that we're anxious
to see added at some point.
But right now, it's just still
something that we're working
through to figure out whether
it's feasible or not.
So stay tuned.
Hopefully, we'll have some good
news, but nothing on the
short term roadmap that really
is going to solve for this
particular use case.
And somebody was asking
about converting MP3s.
That's not what Drive is for, so
the short answer is no, you
cannot use it as a way to
convert your audio files into
different formats.
It would be kind of
cool, but just not
something that we can do.
And let me just check
my notifications.
Oh, and just a couple
of people sitting
there watching now.
But Colby, if you are watching
and you have questions, we
don't have a live chat up--
unless, Dylan, do you have
a live chat up anywhere?
DYLAN: People could comment
on the YouTube video.
STEVE BAZYL: So, yeah.
There is some commenting
on YouTube.
Dylan can read them to me.
But easiest thing for me to see
them is actually just to
post to the community,
and I would happily
answer whatever is posted.
Let me just see if there's a
couple last questions that I
want to talk about.
And if not, we'll wrap up.
But let em just scroll through
here a little bit.
And a lot of stuff about Google
Apps Script, people
doing some really
creative things.
But it looks like
that may be it.
Colby, since you were asking
about live questions, feel
free to post things later.
We'll follow up in the community
or on StackOverflow.
And again, just always happy to
talk to people and figure
out what you're doing.
And certainly, just post in the
forum about what you're
actually building.
We get a little bit of insight
from our logs and from the API
projects, but a lot of times,
all we're seeing is an
application title, which
isn't always the
most informative thing.
So if you are building something
that you think is
just really cool, post in
the community about it.
Let people know.
Let other developers know.
Let us know.
And if it's something really
interesting, we'd love to chat
more about it and see what we
can do to make it better.
So with that, since we're out
of questions, I'm going to
wrap it up.
We will be back next week.
Either Tuesday or
Friday, we'll be
broadcasting from Zurich.
It will be Nicolas.
And lots of cool stuff
on the horizon.
Actually want to just quick
shout out to everyone who
joined the Early
Access program.
We've gotten a lot of
people in there.
If you haven't heard back,
chances are it means you
weren't in.
I haven't sent emails to
everyone to confirm that, but
I'll try to get confirmations
out to everyone just so you
know for sure that we did look
at you and it just wasn't
right fit at this time.
But the people who are in, we're
really happy to see that
people are doing really
interesting stuff and getting
us feedback.
So, keep it coming.
And if you haven't heard and
you still think you can do
some really cool stuff with the
newer features, just apply
again and we'll reconsider.
But we're actually really happy
with how that's turning
out, so great job everyone
who's doing that.
And that's it.
So come back Tuesday, and
we'll see you soon.
All right, thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]